what is going on guys welcome to the
fifth video and image recognition and
manipulation where we left off we were
just showing you guys some matplotlib
and before that how to read the arrays
now let's actually get into some numbers
now and bring up some actual examples so
let's take zero for example and if you
open up and go to your directory and
click on you're going to like the images
part and click on numbers you should
have just a whole bunch of numbers in
here and so this time let's take the
yellow 0.4 so Y 0.4 and that's what
we're gonna consider in this one so let
me bring this back over now and so
instead of images dot now we're actually
images slash numbers slash and the
filename here was y 0.4 dot PNG so now
if we save that run that and put that up
we see that okay that's what we have now
so um this is obviously a blue 0 with a
yellow background subsequently and
actually let's go ahead and we should
probably let's print out print iar so
let's turn out that array real quick and
then we bring that array over and so now
you can see that we have a different a
lot of different number of values right
there's no blue here at all but there's
a pretty sizable amount of green and a
lot of red and obviously full alpha and
in this tutorial we're not even gonna be
touching alpha and later we're gonna
kick alpha out but just now that's
probably always going to be 255 until
you get into some more in depth images
but we're not too worried about that
right now so anyway the numbers are a
little bit different but what if we
looked at and let me just close the
image itself and this time let's change
the number and let's do a basic zero
right so we've got
zero and all these the 0.3 0.4 and this
y 0.5 they're all the exact same zero as
0.1 right so let's bring up 0.1 and run
that Oh
it's non zero a non why take out the Y
there and now run 0.1 and now obviously
same zero that we had before
only it's black and white and it's very
simple and we can look at this and since
we already recognized ourselves what you
know these are so all of these are white
dots and then we've got all these black
dots so for black pixels at the top
right so one two three four oh wow we
are actually going to probably turn into
the matrix at the end of this anyways um
and in neo but how would we know but and
like really the idea of like character
recognition how would we know that both
of these are zeros and then what if we
took it a step further and like really
through you guys for a loop and where
you use y 0.5 mostly this one bring that
one up and now we're looking at it is
like oh okay that's pretty hard on our
eyeballs even try to look at it is I how
do we actually work around this like
whenever like the letters are different
errors or the letters are different
colors and all that how will we
recognize that it's the exact same one
well typically right when you look at
like an OCR like that that 0.5 for
example is kind of hard for a human's
eyes to read but when it comes to a
computer they're just looking at the
patterns and they're generating colors
but it's all numbers to them and it's
very much a different number right this
yellow versus like this tan or whatever
you want to call it is very much a
different number right and so like let's
if we do bring it up again we can even
look here like this is clearly different
than those previously yellow numbers
that we were looking at so that's how we
know and actually so yeah like this is
our our yellow like our background
yellow is 255 240 to 0 and then our this
yellow is 239 228 once
six so none of those are similar this is
very different color so um so the
computer doesn't really have that if
that problem right so the issue that
computers are going to have usually at
like optical recognition is not when the
colors are very similar but it's
actually going to be when there's like a
blur to the image or the or like the
numbers or letters like a blur will make
it hard or like a deformed letter right
like just think about like the CAPTCHA
right like if you want to know what
makes a image recognition heart or
character recognition hard look at a
CAPTCHA and that that's those are the
kinds of things that make it difficult
right it's sometimes those captions make
it so difficult that like even your own
eyeballs have a hard time reading it
luckily though um my goal in this series
is not to teach you guys how to defeat
CAPTCHAs instead it is how to just read
characters no matter what color they are
not all characters are going to have a
pure white background not all characters
are going to be pure black so what do we
do about that well the way that we're
going to do that is to do what's called
threshold and you can you can kind of
solve the problem so the first at least
in our sense we're only using two to two
different colors so all we have to do is
really just make a single center line
and anything that's above a value is you
know going to be white right because the
higher the numbers that the closer to
white they are the lower the numbers
closer black they're so anyways that's
what we're gonna be doing in the next
video its threshold in and so hopefully
that sounds interesting to you guys as
always thanks for watching thanks for
your support your subscriptions and
until next time